[Music]
over a period of seven years we've been
observing terrific growth of these to
London plane trees growing in structural
soil Cu structural soil in Ithaca for as
long as we've been studying structural
soil we've been very interested in how
roots grow through this new medium we
have an opportunity here to actually
excavate the entire root system so we
can transplant this tree safely we
wanted to do this because the trees were
planted under wires this installation
has about a thirty inch depth of
structural soil overlaid with a
geotextile and then a sand setting bed
where pervious pavers are laid on top we
use an air excavation tool to safely
unearth the root system here you can see
the roots you know quite a strong growth
pattern annually moving around and
through the structural soil
the roots start at the surface but very
quickly move down and the profile going
down to at least 24 inches into the tree
pit area
[Music]
we're seeing both massive roots that
tend to go down we might call those
sinka roots as well as large buttress
roots near the surface
after we unearth most of the root system
we took it out of the ground and we
actually transplanted it into a park the
tree here is about six inch caliper tree
it had been planted about one and a half
inches seven years earlier it's been
grown very very well some of those roots
were so deep we actually had to break
them to get the tree out of the ground
[Music]
the root mass that we took out of the
ground was about 13 feet long and about
8 feet wide so quite an extensive root
system
[Music]
we saw some massive roots some really
strongly growing roots in the profile as
well as quite a bit of fine root growth
[Music]
we saw some very interesting features of
how the roots move through the stone
interestingly we saw some gravel that
was actually embedded in the roots we've
actually grown around and captial ating
the stone
[Music]
here again you can see some of the
gravel wedged in between the roots roots
growing right around those
[Music]
and here's a really good example of a
stone being encapsulated actually
growing around the stone and it was
wedged in there quite tightly
as roots grow through structural soil
they often get flattened and then
proceed to grow normally again this
doesn't have any negative effect on root
function so we saw deformation we saw
encapsulation we saw a lot of deep root
growth as well as roots that were up at
the top six inches below the surface we
have lots of evidence now that lutes can
grow very very well in structural soil
and the hope is that as roots grow
deeper there'd be less potential for
sidewalk heaving in the future
[Music]
you